[موسيقى]
مساء الخير في 17 ديسمبر الجاري اصدرت
الحكومه البريطانيه او كشفت الحكومه
البريطانيه عن
ملخص النتائج التي توصلت اليها لجنه
كلفتها الحكومه بتقدير وتقيييم اوضاع
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وهل هي تمثل خطرا
على الحكومه البريطانيه ام لا اللجنه
استغرقت 20 شهر وكشف رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني كاميرون عن اهم ما عن اهم
النتائج الت توصلت اليها اللجنه وخلاصتها
ان جماعه الاخوان المسلمين لم ترتكب ما
يستوجب حظرها على الاراضي البريطانيه
ولكنها اعتبرت ان الانضمام الى هذه
الجماعه مؤشر على وجود تطرف محتمل
وبالتالي اي شخص بينتمي للجماعه يجب النظر
اليه بنوع من الحذر والحيطه وتضمن التقرير
عدد كبير من اوص عدد من الاوصاف للجماعه
اللي اجمالا يمكن اعتباره اوصاف سلبيه لم
تسعد الجماعه على الاطلاق طبعا زي ان هي
توصف الجماعه بانها جماعه غامضه وسريه عن
عمد وان الجماعه جماعه لها قيم معاديه
للقيم البريطانيه ولحقوق الانسان ولحكم
القانون الاجمال الاوصاف السلبيه ديت
اضطرت الجماعه على لسان المكتب المحاماه
اللي هي موكلا انها تهدد بمقاضاته
البريطانيه باعتبار ان التقرير معيب جدا
السؤال هنا هل ممكن هذا التقرير اللي ما
اتكشف كليه لم تكشف الحكومه البريطانيه
كليه عنه يمكن ان يؤثر على العلاقه
القديمه جدا بين لندن وبين الجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وهل يمكن ان يضر
بالعلاقه الخاصه اللي ربطت العاصمه
البريطانيه باهم جماعه اسلام سياسي في
العالم اللي هي جماعه الاخوان المسلمين طب
وايه هي اساسا العلاقه الخاصه اللي بتربط
بريطانيا بهذه الجماعه وبالتالي يمكن ان
ان يكون لتقرير من هذا النوع تاثير سلبي
على مستقبل الجماعه علشان نجاوب على
الاسئله دي لازم نعرف زي ما بقول
لحضراتكم نبذه عن هذا التاريخ اللي ربط
الجماعه ببريطانيا كثير يمكن ما يعرفوش
انه
الجماعه الحقيقه من اللحظات الاولى وحتى
هذه اللحظه يعني قامت في
ظل السلطه البريطانيه والاحتلال البريطاني
لمصر
وكان البذره الاولى للجماعه كانت موجوده
في مدينه الاسماعيليه حيث المقر لاهم رموز
الاحتلال البريطاني لمصر وهي شركه قناه
السويس وتحت سمع وبصر الجماعه تحت سمع
وبصر السلطات البريطانيه بدا الشيخ حسن
البنا اللي كان منتدب كمدرس هناك في مدينه
الاسماعيليه بتاسيس جماعته بل ان اول دعم
حصل عليه الشيخ حسن البنا حصل عليه من
السلطات من شركه قناه السويس اللي هي
الشركه البريطانيه طبعا وكان مبلغ ضخم جدا
وقتها حوالي 500 جنيه مصري لتاسيس مسجد
ومقر للجماعه وخلافه وتطورت علاقه الجماعه
على مض من سنه 28 الى الان في عمليات جذب
وشد لكن كانت دائما بريطانيا ولندن ا بصفه
رئيسيه ملجا وملاذ للاخوان المسلمين كلما
ضقت بهم الدنيا وكلما قست عليهم ضربات
حكام في الدول العربيه المختلفه سواء مصر
سواء سوريا وغيرهم من الدول خارج العالم
العربي الحقيقه انه قبل ما اتكلم على انه
يعني ليه بريطانيا بتعمل كده احب اقول انه
بريطانيا مش بس بترتبط بعلاقه خاصه بجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين لا بريطانيا منذ اكثر من
100 سنه يعني حتى قبل تاسيس جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين كانت حريصه جدا انها توثق
علاقتها باكبر عدد ممكن من الجماعات
الاسلاميه وزي ما قال مؤرخ بريطاني متخصص
في تاريخ الامبراطوريه البريطانيه اسمه
فرانسيس روبنسون ان كان دايما الساس
البريطانيين لاسباب متعدده بيجد ضلتهم في
رجال الدين الاسلاميين وبيعتمد ان من
خلالهم ممكن يدعموا نفوذهم في الدول في
المستعمرات البريطانيه وقال عباره قاسيه
شويه ان وينستن تشيرشل كان بيعتقد انه
يمكن التلاعب والاحتيال على بعض رجال
الدين الاسلاميين اكثر من غيرهم خصوصا
الطامح منهم في انه يلعب دور سياسي لاحظوا
ان اهم جماعتين اسلاميتين في التاريخ
الحديث الجماعات اللي ساعت الى احياء
الخلافه الاسلاميه والى احياء الدين على
الاقل من منظور من منظرهم يعني قاموا تحت
مظله الخلافه الامبراطوريه البريطانيه
الجماعه الاولانيه ديو باندي اللي هي
الجماعه الهنديه المعروفه اللي تاسست سنه
والجماعه دي اللي خرج منها ابو الاعلى
المودودي احد الملهمين لافكار سيد قطب احد
اهم اقطاب جماعه الاخوان والمسلمين ويعتبر
المنظر الاول للجماعات التكفيريه باعتباره
ان هو صاحب نظريه
الحاكميه حاكميه الله
و وجاهل المجتمع وكمان من تحت عباءه جماعه
ديوب اندي اللي اتاسس زي ما قلت لحضراتكم
سنه 1866 خرجت جماعه طالبان واللي عدد
كبير من الائمه المنتمين اليها حتى هذه
اللحظه بيسيطر وفقا لتقرير استخباراتي
اتنشر في عدد من الصحف البريطانيه على 600
مسجد من اجمالي 1350 هي اجمالي عدد
المساجد في بريطانيا طيب دي جماعه ديو
باندي وكذلك جماعه الاخوان المسلمين كان
بايه الهدف اللي كان دائما بيخلي او بيدفع
الامبراطوريه البريطانيه العظمى الى
احتضان هذه الجماعات رغم ادراكهم الكامل
ان هذه الجماعات بتعتبر عدو اذا ما كانش
على المنظور القريب ففي المنظور البعيد هم
عدو يجب محاربتهم وبيعتبر كفارا وبيعتبر
عدوا على عدوا للاسلام ويستهدف ايه كانت
فكرتهم الفكره باختصار ان بريطانيا رغم
ادراكها لكل ده كانت بتشوف ان هذه
الجماعات يمكن توظيفها مرحليا لتحقيق
اهداف ريبه ثم وقتها بعد تحقيق هذه
الاهداف يبتدوا يعيدوا النظر في علاقتهم
بهذه الجماعات اما بضربها او بسجنها او
بالتخلي عنها او بترك امرهم الى الانظمه
القمعيه اللي حكمت العالم العربي والعالم
الاسلامي لعشرات السنوات وممكن اقول
لحضراتكم بشكل موجز لان المساله يعني فيها
تفاصيل كتيره على امثله كثيره جدا تعاونت
فيها بريطانيا واعتمدت فيها على الجماعات
الاسلاميه المختلفه سواء جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين او غيرهم او حتى جماعه ديو باندي
او غيرهم من الجماعات اللي حملت اسماء
مختلفه لتحقيق اهداف واضحه تخدم مصالح
البريطانيه مثلا على سبيل
المثال في سنه 53 ظهر شخصيه وطنيه اسمه
محمد مصدق واللي بيحمل احد واللي اسمه
اطلق على احد الشوارع في حي المهندسين في
مصر شارع مشهور في المهندسين في حي
المهندسين بالقاهره محمد مصدق ده كان رئيس
وزراء ايران ظاهر سنه 53 وكان عنده ميول
واضحه للاستقلال
ولتاكيد
والامريكيه لما حبوا يتخلصوا منه لم يجدوا
الا حلفائهم من الجماعات الاسلاميه
المختلفه للتخلص من الرجل واسقطه في هذا
العام المساله تكررت مثلا في الاردن لما
ظهر رئيس وزراء رئيس وزراء اردني منتخب
اللي هو سليمان النابولسي سنه 57 وكان على
خلاف مع الملك حسين اللي هو كان يعني ا
يعني رجل بتجمع علاقات قويه جدا بالغرب وب
سواء بريطانيا وبعدها الولايات المتحده
وجد الملك نفسه مضطرا وكذلك بريطانيا و
وغيرها من الحلفاء الغربيين الى استخدام
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين لضرب النابولسي
باعتباره رجل يساري محسوب على الشيوعيين
وكمان محسوب على ا الزعيم المصري جمال عبد
الناصر وبالتالي تم استخدام الجماعه الى
ضربه وقيل في وقت من الاوقات ان الملك وفر
لهم بعض الاسلحه لارهاب اليسار اللي موجود
في الاردن هل معنى كلام اللي انا بقوله ان
الجماعه دي سواء الاخوان او ديو باندي او
غيرهم هي جماعات عميله اطلاقا ليس هذا ما
اقصده بالعكس هذه الجماعات بتضم اعداد
كبيره جدا من الشباب النقي الراغب في انه
ا يعني يعبر او يحمي دينه
وا يدافع عن دينه كما يراه ولكن الفكره مش
هو نوايا الاعداد الغالبيه العظمى من
الشباب المنضم او الكوادر سواء للاخوان او
غير الاخوان لكن الفكره في انه كيف يتم
توظيف هذه
الجماعات من قبل الدول الكبرى سواء
بريطانيا سابقا والان والولايات المتحده
وحتى بعض الدول العربيه زي السعوديه وزي
مصر انها ظ في هذه الجماعات مرحليا لتحقيق
هدف معين احيانا الجماعات دي بتعتقد انه
لا باس من ده لانه انا يمكن يكون دوت
بيوافق هوا في نفسي لكن سرعان ما تسعى هذه
الدول للتخلص من هذه الجماعات ما ان ينتهي
الهدف الاساسي منها بالمناسبه القصه دي مش
مقتصره على العالم العربي ولا علاقه
بريطانيا مقتصره على جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وديو بندي ده ما تنسوش ان
بريطانيا ده ده في دول كثيره ما تنسوش ان
بريطانيا طيا بحكم انها كانت الامبراطوريه
التي لا تغرب عنها الشمس كانت بتبسط
نفوذها على اكثر من نصف شعوب العالم
الاسلامي سواء في افريقيا في اسيا في وفي
غيرهم من القارات على سبيل المثال في
خلافه اسلاميه منسيه في التاريخ احنا لما
بنتكلم على الخلافه الاسلاميه بنعد اما
الخلافه الرشيده او بنتكلم على تجربه هنا
وتجربه هناك وبننسى ان في خلافه قامت
لاكثر من 100 سنه في نيجيريا في شمال
نيجيريا اسمها خلافه سكوته واسسها الشيخ
عثمان ابن فودي في سنه 1802 واستمرت ل
1903 ويمكن بعدها بعده سنوات واقامت خلافه
ضمت حوالي 30 اماره وضمت اجزاء من خارج
نيجيريا لكن في كل الاحوال جمعت
اثناء فتره عمر هذه الخلافه علاقه مضطربه
ويعني متذبذبه بينها وبين الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه في
1903 لما تازم العلاقه ورات بريطانيا ان
الخليفه السكوتي اصبح يمثل تهديدا على
مصالحها ضربته بالمدافع حتى اخضعت سيطرتها
على مقدرات الخلافه لكن ما ان خضعت
الخلافه الى التصورات والى ودخلت بيت
الطاعه البريطاني لم تمانع ابدا في ان
الخليفه يستمر ويطبق الشريعه كما يشاء
ويسير في طريقه طالما انه ينسق
مع المندوب السام البريطاني ولا تتعارض
تصرفاته مع بريطانيا بعد كده اعمل اللي
انت عاوزه بل بالعكس كانت بتشوف في السلطه
الدينيه التقليديه من خلال تطبيق الشريعه
او من خلال رجال الدين فرصه ان هي تبسط
نفوذها على مستعمراتها الكثيره القصه دي
تكررت زي ما بقول لحضراتكم في كثير من
الدول ليس فقط تاريخيا ولكن كمان في
الحاضر وقبل ما اتكلم على الحاضر القريب
قوي اقول انه
بريطانيا رغم وخلال تاريخها الكبير مع
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين كانت بتستغل
الجماعه ل عده اغراض كان احد اهم هذه
الاغراض ضرب الحركه القوميه اللي بدات
بشكل كبير مع جمال عبد الناصر وفي عدد
كبير من الدول ليه تضرب الحركه القوميه
العربيه وما تضربش الحركه الاسلاميه يعني
ليه تناصر بلد زي بريطانيا حركه قوميه
يساريه علمانيه وفي نفس الوقت عندها
استعداد تدعم حركه اسلاميه الاجابه
باختصار ودي
قالها يعني مسؤول امريكي اسمه غايب عن
ذهني لكن هو موجود عموما في بحث قيم جدا
كتبه في سنه اواخر 2012 كان بيتكلم على
ثورات الربيع العربي في مقوله في مقال
مطول ذس از نوت ريفلوشن او هذه ليست ثوره
هذا المسؤول الامريكي رخص القصه ان
بالنسبه لبريطانيا ولاحقا الولايات
المتحده بتجد من السهل جدا التعامل مع
الحركات الاسلاميه خلافا للحركات القوميه
او
الخلافات العلمانيه
او يعني الحركات القوميه اللي داعيه
للتحرر في مقابل الحركات الاسلاميه لان
الحركات اللي من نوعيه مثلا فتح في فلسطين
بتطلب من القوى اللي بتتعامل معاها زي
اسرائيل في حاله فتح مطالب محدده مثلا
حدود ما بعد
نصف اراضي
محدده طبقا لاتفاقات اقرتها الامم المتحده
وليس على كامل فلسطين التاريخيه فيما ان
حماس في المقابل اللي هي بتمثل جماعه
الاخوان في فلسطين بتطلب امور اخرى انه
كامل فلسطين التاريخيه القضاء تماما على
اسرائيل او اليهود وبالتالي تدرك الولايات
اسرائيل ان هذه النوع من المطالب يصعب جدا
انه يتحقق وان انت اذا كنت بتربط تحقق
مطالبك
ب قيام الساعه وانه دوت هتبقى حرب نهايه
التاريخ يبقى جيد انا اعيش معاك في عمليه
جذب وشد الى ان تقوم الساعه دون ان
تطالبني بمطالب واضحه محدده يضطر المجتمع
الدولي ان يضغط عل لتنفيذها هي صحيح
اسرائيل ما بتعملش لا ده ولا ده لكن يسهل
عليها انها تتعامل مع حماس على اعتبار ان
المطالب انه حربها مع ان حماس مستعده او
الجماعات الاخرى مستعده انها تقبل باوضاع
مختلفه لانها تضمر في نفسها ان هذه اوضاع
مؤقته حتى يختل موازين القوه بالتالي تقدر
ان هي تحصل على كامل فلسطين التاريخيه
وهذا ما ترحب به اسرائيل لانها تدرك انه
يصع تحقيقه طيب فيما يتعلق عوده الى
بريطانيا مره اخرى
بريطانيا حتى بعد ان اصبحت يعني دوله مهمه
ولكن ليست قوه عظمى احتفظت بنفس السياسه
انها تجمع على اراضيها وتستقبل على
اراضيها اكبر عدد ممكن من جماعات
الاسلاميه سواء جماعه الاخوان او الجماعه
الاسلاميه او جماعات مختلفه او حزب
التحرير كل انواع الجماعات كل انواع
الجماعات بتستقبل على على اراضيها وخاصه
في العاصمه البريطانيه وعدد كبير جدا انت
شوف اي عدد من القض الاسلامين اللي خارجين
من بلدانهم واضرب ودور على اسمه كده في
الانترنت هتجد بشكل
اما اقام في بريطانيا لفتره طويله جدا او
تردد على زيارتها لفترات طويله بريطانيا
كانت بتعتقد من السياسه دي اللي بتتبعها
حتى هذه اللحظه ان باستخدامها باستقبالها
للاسلاميين هي بتحقق عده امور احد هذه
الامور انه تامن على نفسها من مكر هذه
الجماعات ومن شرورها لان اولا اذا ما كانش
هم طبعا هيكونوا حريصين ان ما يضرو بقدر
كبير المكان اللي بويه لكن حتى لو فكروا
فهذه الاقامات ليست اقامات مجانيه فهم تحت
وسمع تحت سمع وبصر كل الجامعات كل الاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه البريطانيه وبالتالي هم
عارفين كويس هم بيفكروا في ايه الامر
الثاني انه يستخدموا المعلومات الكتيره
اللي بيجمعو من ا هذه الكوادر اللي موجوده
على ارضها في الضغط على بلدانهم سواء مثلا
الضغط على مصر زي ما بيحصل دلوقتي انه انا
بجهز للبديل ان في حاله وجود سقوط الحكومه
اللي موجوده او تعرض النظام اللي بيرقصه
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي لاي متاعب يبقى
في الحاله دي انا عندي البديل
موجود نفس القصه في السعوديه فهم استقبلوا
عدد كبير من معارضيهم موجودين استقروا في
لندن لفتره طويله للضغط على السعود وفي
حال تعرض النظام هناك لاي مشكله يبقى
عندهم البديل دائما بيستخدموا هذه
الجماعات
ل لهذه الاغراض في ديسمبر 2011 كتب شخص
مهم جدا اسمه روبرت لامبرت وهو كان مسؤول
وحده الاتصال بالمسلمين في الشرطه
الانجليزيه او اه بالضبط كده في الشرطه
البريطانيه لان احنا يجب ان نفخر ان احنا
الكلام ده بعد ثورات الربيع العربي ان
احنا استقبلنا على اراضينا عدد كبير جدا
من الجماعات الاسلاميه وخصوصا جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وبعد كل هذه السنين
عادوا الى بلدانهم ليقودوا حركه التغيير
واحنا على علاقه طيبه بيه وبالتالي يكون
للندن نفوس كبير بهذه الجماعات الحقيقه
عن انه كل اللي انا بقوله دوت عشان اؤكد
او انا استنتج انه التقرير الاخير وان كان
ضربه اخبار غير ساره للجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين ول مؤيديهم الا انها مجه اليقين
ليست الا صحابه صيف الجماعه تحتاج الى
بريطانيا بشده كما ان الجماعه ما ان
بريطانيا تحتاج جماعه تحتاج جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين تماما حتى وهي ا يعني ليست في
اقوى حالاتها استاذنكم انه في الحلقه
الجايه بنتكلم على كيف يمكن ان يؤثر هذا
التقرير ا على الاقل في المرحله المقبله
على حركه الجماعه داخل بريطانيا واوروبا
ونتكلم كمان على علاقه هذه الجماعات بحليف
ووريث بريطانيا في حكم العالم الولايات
المتحده وعلاقه الولايات المتحده بجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وباقي الجماعات الاخرى
الاسلاميه في العالم اشكركم والى لقاء اخر
باذن الله